hello everyone during josa counseling
the top choice for most students are the
circular departments meaning computer
science electronics and electrical
immediately after this among the
non-circular branches
it can be arguably said that the top
choice for students is generally
mechanical engineering however when
filling these choices students often
take an uninformed decision meaning they
choose mechanical
without really understanding the various
aspects of mechanical engineering
department
so in this video I thought it'll be a
good idea if I can give a broad overview
of the department mechanical engineering
department
I shall divide this video broadly into
three parts in the first part I am going
to discuss the various types of courses
which are taught in mechanical
engineering this is very important
second I shall be discussing two
surprising aspects of mechanical
engineering which I am sure most
students are not aware of and third I am
going to discuss based on these first
two things the suitability of mechanical
engineering for different kinds of
students
so at the very first the different kinds
of courses which students have to study
now broadly mechanical engineering is
divided into three divisions first you
have the applied mechanics or design and
Dynamics now in certain institutes like
IIT Delhi and IIT Madras you have
actually a separate applied mechanics
division but broadly
uh in most institutes you have the
design and Dynamics division within
mechanical engineering which is also
sometimes referred to as the applied
mechanics division in this division the
kinds of courses which you have to
undergo are solid mechanics Dynamics
machine design vibration analysis
control
and in certain places robotics although
at IIT kharagpur robotics comes under
another division
now as a plus two student as a student
who is just past plus two you may not be
quite aware of these things so very
quickly I'll go through them well solid
mechanics you have to deal with
mechanics of solid bodies of course but
meaning deformable solids okay so the
deformation is important in Dynamics you
usually deal with rigid bodies so this
is the subject which is the closest with
what you study in the mechanics part of
physics at plus two
the problems are very similar although
much more advanced level like if you
thought that mechanic set on the GE
level is difficult you should see the
problems in Dynamics but it's very
exciting also and many students find it
fascinating absolutely although very
challenging
and it is it goes beyond particle level
Dynamics uh next you have things like
vibration analysis which comes in the
later years uh this goes beyond things
like simple harmonic motion wave motion
uh that sort of thing and in control you
have uh of course the how do you how do
you go about controlling various aspects
of mechanics
now control is something which has a
very very close resemblance with what
people study in Electrical Engineering
also
next division is the thermal and fluid
fluid Sciences uh or thermal and fluids
engineering here of course you study
fluid mechanics heat transfer
thermodynamics the three pillars of this
Division and then you also have a lot of
Applied things like applied
thermodynamics turbo Machinery internal
combustion engines so in fluid mechanics
uh it is like a close counterpart of
solid mechanics you apply mechanics to
fluid flow where you have a little bit
of a introduction to it in your plus two
physics but very very little things
where you talk about positive flu
Reynolds number these sort of things but
it goes much much beyond that talking
about things like Navi Stokes equations
the famous navistokes equations and uh
pretty source of aspects associated with
field mechanics field flow next in heat
transfer you talk about things of course
conduction convection and radiation but
it goes much much beyond the kind of
things which you have learned in high
school uh
and in thermodynamics uh of course it
builds on what you studied in you know
plus two but there are a lot of new
things which you have to study also and
very importantly within mechanical
engineering thermodynamics as you study
it in the undergraduate it is applied to
a lot of application areas that that is
what you study
now then third division is manufacturing
in certain places it is referred to as
production now manufacturing as the name
searches is other kind of courses where
you study uh how do you make how to make
things basically it's that but within
that there are certain classical courses
like casting forming welding as well as
machine tools and machining these are
some of the very traditional kinds of
fabrication or manufacturing processes
in addition to that you also get to
study some kind of non-traditional
manufacturing things involving uh
applications of electromagnetism as well
as laser now these are not newfangled
things these are very classical things
within Manufacturing in science and
engineering although they are referred
to as non-traditional things you also
get to study things like as a very small
example because you do not have much
ideable manufacturing you also get to
study some very exciting things like
cutting metal with a jet of water so
believe it or not that is possible
all right so these are the various kinds
of courses a very very uh like a
blazingly fast overview of the various
kinds of courses you can take a look at
the detailed uh syllabus uh the
curriculum in any good
Institute website
now the next thing that I want to
discuss is the second part of this video
I want to discuss a couple of surprising
aspects of mechanical engineering which
most students are not aware of now if
you have just listened to what I said
about the different courses it is
natural for you to think that yes most
of these courses seem to be like
application areas of what you are
studying in physics and plus two and
that is true but what people do not
realize is that a lot of the topics
Within These courses
uh from all the three divisions
but mostly mostly from the design and
Dynamics as well as from the thermal and
fluid part
they are they can be considered to be
Applied Mathematics okay they can be
considered to be applications of Applied
Mathematics this is something which
people absolutely do not realize I want
to emphasize this because many of the
good students who come through the je
process into these engineering
Institutes
uh they are uh somewhat strong in
mathematics many of them are very strong
in mathematics and because they are
strong in mathematics they have also
been through uh they have also
participated in olympiads
and uh it just so happens that the
Olympiad syllabus is uh more
concentrated towards the pre-calculus
things meaning uh things involving
algebra geometry permutations and
combinations and of course number Theory
so there's not much calculus in that and
these students they think that they are
good in mathematics and they are maybe
good in Olympiad level problems so
because they are good in mathematics
they should not be taking mechanical
engineering maybe they should go into
they are only mostly suitable for
mathematics and Computing and computer
science that is true if you're really
good at Olympiad level problems in
mathematics you are definitely suitable
for those departments mathematics and
Computing and computer science but what
people do not realize and this is what
what I want to emphasize here is that in
mathematics within the pure math side
you have these things but there is an
entirely separate thing called Applied
Mathematics where things are built up on
the foundations of calculus and not just
the kind of calculus which you have been
exposed to in your plus two rather the
kind of multivariate calculus which is
extremely extremely exciting and
fascinating and these are the kinds of
things in Applied Mathematics which
finds a lot of applications in physical
problems and a lot of these problems are
there in the areas of solid mechanics
and fluid mechanics please note that
when I mention these things I'm not just
referring to things which are taught at
the higher levels okay you do not have
to even go for higher studies to realize
that the that you are actually studying
things which are basically applications
of Applied Mathematics
in your very undergraduate level courses
also you will realize this
in fact it is true to such an extent
that
I would say that people who are
not very keen on doing mathematics
should think twice about taking
mechanical engineering there is so much
of Applied maths in mechanical
engineering
the next thing which I want to highlight
is
many students at their school level they
get interested in computer programming
this is quite common nowadays
and based on this interest they think
that they are suitable mostly for
computer science and engineering but the
funny thing is in hardcore computer
science the the intellectual core of
computer science does not have too much
to do with programming now when I say
this I am making a distinction between
the hardcore part of computer science
separately from the software engineering
part where of course there is a huge lot
of programming there is no denying that
but the hardcore aspect of computer
science and engineering does not have
does not is not intrinsically uh
dependent on programming there are other
much more intellectually deeper things
there now suppose an is a student is
there who is really really interested in
the programming aspects okay and at the
same time he is interested in things uh
in in scientific things so I would say
the most natural choice for him would be
physics
this is this is the most Natural Choice
of course when students are not keen on
taking a basic Sciences after finishing
je successfully so the next best option
I would say is mechanical engineering
and when I say mechanical engineering I
also I broadly mean
the Department's based on the mechanical
Sciences like mechanical engineering
Aerospace and also uh separately
chemical engineering
because there's a lot a lot of computer
programming involved there if you're the
kind of student who is who has a good
Knack of visualizing complex geometry in
your head and you are also interested in
how those things can be applied to
various kinds of physical problems
using programming then there is a very
very fertile area for you to work in uh
in mechanical engineering this is the
place to be
now when I say these things it certainly
does not mean that from the various
first day that you start studying
mechanical engineering you are going to
be able to do these things you'll be
able to do these things only at the
higher levels maybe when you do some
kind of projects and certainly when you
go into higher studies
all right the next aspect that I want to
discuss based on all these discussions
that I've had till now is the
suitability of mechanical engineering
for the various students I'd already
mentioned a very important point that
because there is so much of Applied
maths in mechanical engineering if
you're the kind of student who is
actually very good in maths then you
should really think about taking up
mechanical engineering like if you're
really really good in maths you have a
certain knack for it there is a big
chance that will be able to do very well
especially if you go into higher studies
and into the academic line on the
contrary
if you are the kind of student who is
not very keen on maths okay somehow you
want to avoid it then maybe
just because your your rank is allowing
you to take mechanical engineering don't
just jump into it think twice think
twice before taking up mechanical
engineering there may be a few other
departments where you may be able to
thrive better than mechanical
engineering even though even though your
rank is allowing it okay so uh I I keep
on I try to emphasize this point again
and again just because your rank is uh
suitable for certain Department uh is
allowing you to take a certain
department whether it's even a circular
Department don't just jump into it try
to realize what kind of thing your brain
is attuned to okay we had a very famous
Professor in mechanical engineering
department uh he's uh he's gone now he's
passed away a few years ago he used to
say
not everything is for everybody
okay this is a very very important line
and thing to understand okay not
everything is for everybody you have to
find so a big recipe for success in life
is to find the thing which you are most
suitable of doing I think Albert
Einstein also uh a famous quote is
attributed to him is that if you if you
ask a fish to climb a tree of course it
is going to fail okay so find find your
find your water find your domain finally
I've said a lot of things very good
things about mechanical engineering very
challenging things which are there in
mechanical engineering but at the end I
would say that some of the most exciting
things in mechanical engineering in
order to be able to reach that level you
have to go into the higher levels of
mechanical engineering you have to go
into the higher studies if your
intention however is to somehow get a
job
okay just at the end of four years of
study then this is probably not the way
to go okay then so this is probably the
situation with the most most average
students they somehow want to get a job
then maybe think twice think twice
before choosing your department okay
going to a department where there is the
most chance of getting a job even if you
happen to have a mediocre result go for
it but I I want to emphasize again if
you're really interested in the kind of
things which you have discussed in this
video
go for mechanical engineering you will
actually be intrinsically happy and I
think if somebody is really interested
and happy on a day-to-day basis learning
something and actively pursuing
something then there is a greater chance
for him to succeed in that line of
career so with this word of advice I'll
end this video thank you very much and
all the best